[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
nicolas bay bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député
européen membre du rassemblement
national vice-président du groupe
identité et démocratie au parlement
européen merci d'être avec nous ce matin
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenter
ce matin par pascal jalabert au journal
du groupe
hébrard les journaux régionaux de l'est
de la france on commence par cette crise
sanitaire nicolas bay et jean castex qui
finalement n'a annoncé aucune mesure
restrictive pour faire face à la
recrudescence de l'épidémie de coville
est ce qu'il a bien fait jean castex je
crois qu'il ya une nécessité absolue
c'est la clarté parce que c'est la
clarté qui a fait défaut depuis le début
de cette crise sanitaire et on a un
gouvernement finalement acquis à chaque
fois qu'il est dans une situation où il
faut prendre des décisions et sans doute
des décisions difficiles à prendre et
bien se caractérise par une sorte de
flottement on entend des voix
discordantes et c'est ce qui avait
abouti on s'en souvient il ya quelques
mois seulement au début de la crise
sanitaire a entendu tout et son
contraire tout et n'importe quoi nous
expliquer que les masques n'était pas
utile tout simplement parce qu'on était
incapable d'en fournir on nous
expliquait que les tester tout le monde
n'était pas utile alors que a de toute
évidence aujourd'hui dont on voit bien
que c'est très important de tester
massivement parce que ça permet ensuite
isolés de traiter bon donc la nécessité
s'est pas temps de prendre une mesure
forte ou symboliques qui serait une
solution magique tout mon avis la
compagnie qui en avait pas et qu'il va
falloir en effet vivre avec 7,7 ce virus
et et la menace qu'il représente sans
doute encore pendant plusieurs mois
mais responsabiliser plutôt que de
servir c'est la bonne méthode
oui mais c'est pas forcément ce que fait
le gouvernement jusqu'à maintenant il
est infantilisé les français il a essayé
de les voilà de de traiter nos
compatriotes
voilà comme des enfants avec des des
mesures parfois contradictoires entre
elles
alors que les français ont fait preuve
d'un grand sens des responsabilités
les français ont fait preuve de beaucoup
de civisme de beaucoup de discipline
alors que ce sont les libertés
fondamentales qui ont été quand même
renier de manière majeure comme jamais
dans notre histoire politique récente
donc je crois que la contrepartie c'est
que le gouvernement doit voilà doit dire
la vérité aux français et doit prendre
les mesures claires et cohérentes et ne
veut ne pas avoir une kyrielle de la
demande dit pas la vérité aux français
aujourd'hui
mo je nomme je dis pas que
ponctuellement aujourd'hui dit pas la
vérité je dis simplement que d'une
manière générale on doit avoir une
cohérence entre les décisions qui sont
prises ont restreint les libertés
individuelles
sans doute est ce en partie nécessaire
mais la contrepartie c'est de dire aux
français voilà que les décisions soient
claires qu'on n'est pas en fonction des
territoires ddt et des décisions
totalement contradictoires voilà les
français je pense accepteront encore de
faire preuve de beaucoup de discipline
pendant plusieurs mois ils attendent
simplement que le gouvernement dise les
choses clairement avec des règles
claires qui s'applique de manière
cohérente quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé à nantes là où il ya une rave
party où on beaucoup assumé ne pas voir
le masque les manifestations des jeunes
même si a pas eu grand monde
beaucoup avancé non masqué peut-on
vraiment faire confiance ou alors de
temps en temps mais faut-il irait avec
des amendes et des mesures beaucoup plus
strictes écoutez je crois que c'est
surtout le problème de deux réunions où
il n'y a pas d'organisateur identifié
qui veille à ce que les mesures
barrières soient respectés et c'est
exactement ce qu'elle à cette
manifestation et gilet jaune derrière
c'est plus tellement d gilet jaune c'est
surtout des cagoules noires
on voit bien que c'est ça a été ça
mouvement qui a été complètement
parasite est dénaturée par l'extrême
gauche
je rappelle que initialement les gilet
jaune c'est un mouvement contre l'hyper
fiscalité que c'est contre le les excès
de taxes sur le carburant et puis ça a
révélé la fracture démocratique la
fracture territoriale et mouvements que
le rassemblement national soutenaient
oui bien sûr au son des nappes on assure
t plus aujourd'hui c'est pas ça c'est
qu'on a apporté une réponse politique
on comprenait évidemment les
revendications des gilet jaune on
apporte une réponse politique
la frontière démocratique les nécessités
par exemple
de mettre en oeuvre un système ferrain
d'air d'avoir les modes de scrutin qui
soit démocratique c'est la
proportionnelle
la facture fiscale c'est en finir avec
l'hyper fiscalité la france 47 % de son
pib en prélèvements obligatoires ce qui
fait de nous un des pays les plus
fiscalisé au monde
voilà ça et donc on apporte des réponses
sur ce politique c'est notre rôle de
parti politique
on soutenait le mouvement des gilet
jaune au départ aujourd'hui tout le
monde a bien compris que c'est depuis
les gilet jaune
tout le monde a bien complète l'extrême
gauche a réussi progressivement à
parasiter ce mouvement est aujourd'hui
il est ici réduit comme peau de chagrin
on a eu finalement très peu de
manifestants et dont et dont beaucoup
sont très éloignées qui se présentent
aujourd'hui vous ne souhaitez plus il y
a il reste sans doute au milieu de ces
manifestants quelques gilet jaune
sincère donc on peut toujours aller
soutenir mais en tout cas on soutient
évidemment pas les milices d'extrême
gauche qui qui aujourd'hui ont essayé de
récupérer ce mouvement
allez on va passer à l'actualité de
l'union européenne puisque je rappelais
vous êtes député européen de nicolas bay
c'est d'abord ce plan de relance plan de
relance de 100 milliards présenté par la
france sur lequel l'union européenne va
se prononcer puisque elle le finance à
40% est ce que vous le soutenez ce plan
est ce que vous le vôtre et le plan
relance à français et si on distinguer
les choses
le plan de relance français de 100
milliards présenté par bruno le maire il
ya quelques jours
tout le monde comprend bien que c'est
une goutte d'eau évidemment le chiffre
de 100 milliards peut sembler
impressionnant mais apportée à la
situation du pays on a une dette
publique est passée de 2200 à 2500
milliards
on a un chômage qui était déjà très
élevé avant la crise qu'il est encore
beaucoup plus aujourd'hui ça reste assez
limitée on a eu l'occasion de rappeler
que ce qui fait défaut notamment ce sont
des vraies mesures fortes en direction
des tpe pme parce que c'est là que les
emplois sont menacés c'est là que les
faillites risquent d'être très
nombreuses
or le gouvernement s'est focalisée
essentiellement et et on voit de
l'argent et les subventions
essentiellement sur les grands groupes
donc c'est sans doute la première grande
faille je dis pas qu'il faut pas
soutenir un certain nombre de fleurons
de grands groupes français qui sont
menacés mais en tout cas il faut quand
même soutenir les tpe pme notamment par
des annulations et pas simplement des
reports des charges fiscales et sociales
parce que la perte de
de chiffre d'affaires ces derniers mois
est là elle a eu un caractère définitif
et irréversible
donc le simple report ne n'empêchera pas
les faillites et n'empêchera pas les le
chômage dans d'un certain nombre de
secteurs
donc le plan il est insuffisant mais
vous parliez du plan européen
il a un peu les mêmes défauts en réalité
le plan européen il ya par exemple 750
milliards donc évidemment c'est très
impressionnant comme chiffres sauf que à
l'échelle continentale 27 pays
ça suffit s'est finalement pas grand
chose dans chaque pays la france devrait
toucher 38 ou 39 milliards dans ce plan
mais la question ce n'est pas de savoir
combien de toucher c'est à dire combien
leur pays
or il ya neuf pays contributeurs nets au
budget de l'union européenne dont la
france n'est pas des moindres et donc il
est évident que nous on va payer
beaucoup plus dans les années qui
viennent
parce que cette dette faudra la
rembourser qu'est-ce qu'on va toucher
aujourd'hui donc le non seulement on va
ça va rien doit rapporter ça va nous
coûter comme à chaque fois avec l'union
européenne mais de surcroît c'est pas
nous qui allons décider comment cet
argent va être utilisée puisque c'est la
commission européenne qui a la main donc
sur l allemagne l usage qui est fait de
cet argent
donc vous vous y opposer à ce plan oui
nous nous sommes opposés au plan tel
qu'il a été présenté
et puis il ya un certain que je vais pas
rentrer dans tous les aspects techniques
mais un certain nombre de dispositions
qui sont assez scandaleuse on on essaie
d'attaquer la hongrie et la pologne
en bloquant les aides financières
européennes parce que les choix
politiques ils font contre l'immigration
par exemple ne plaisent pas à bruxelles
on voit surtout qu'il n'ya pas de plus
value en fait la vraie question que
derrière c'est ça qu'elle est la plus
value de faire les choses à l'échelle de
l'union européenne n'y a aucune plus
value on voit bien prendra pas plus
d'argent quand on donne on n'aura pas
une dette moins élevée au contraire et
que de surcroît on est dans une espèce
de carcans qui est pas forcé avec des
contraintes qui sont totalement
dissociée de nos intérêts à nous dire
que l'union européenne va nous demander
d'utiliser l'argent de telle ou telle
manière alors que l'intérêt de la france
ce serait au contraire de se focaliser
sur d'autres secteurs donc voilà on en a
on aurait plutôt intérêt à reprendre nos
billes à et à prendre les décisions au
niveau national mais soyons clairs cette
crise qu'elle a révélé c'est aussi qu'il
y avait il ya des pays qui avaient une
situation économique et financière saine
avant la crise ils ont une capacité à
rebondir
évidemment bien meilleure que nous que
la france qui avait déjà un chômage
endémique qui avait déjà des défis
public très lourd qui avaient déjà une
dette exorbitante qui avait franchi la
barre des 100% du pib avant la crise
sanitaire elle et l'autre actualité
l'union européenne c'est cette crise
migratoire des incendies qui ont ravagé
le camp de migrants de moria sur l'île
de lesbos et hier dans le parisien
clément bonne secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes qui déclare nous
sommes prêts à accueillir dans les
prochains jours une centaine de migrants
parmi ceux qui ont vécu le drame de
moria notamment des mineurs isolés est
ce qu il a raison clément bonnet ce que
la france doit faire preuve de
solidarité d'humanité mais il a
totalement tort pourquoi parce que dit
on va accueillir 100 migrants et chaque
pays va de son p'tit de son petit geste
eh bien ça va inciter des centaines
d'autres à venir des milliers d'autres
des dizaines de milliers d'autres et
donc en fait le ya rien drame sanitaire
et humanitaire un conte donc en fait
rien on ne les agréent l'envers c'est
pas ça il ya un drame à morialmé
pourquoi il ya un drame maria parce
qu'on les a laissés venir parce qu'on
les a laissés s'installer là et qu'on
n'a pas mis en oeuvre les mesures de
fermeté à la fois en amont pour les
empêcher de venir et en aval pour les
renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine
on sait très bien que ceux qui sont
allés à lesbos comme ceux qui pleurent
qui arrivent sur les côtes italiennes en
sicile etc ne viennent pas du ne fuit
pas la guerre il ya une infime minorité
qui fut la guerre il ne fuit pas les
persécutions et ne sont pas éligibles au
droit d'asile
ils viennent pour des raisons
économiques et donc on ne peut pas
accepter cette immigration là et à
chaque fois qu'on qu'on se donne bonne
conscience et que on a les gouvernements
qu'ils disent on va en accueillir
quelques centaines on va prendre notre
part et bien évidemment ça va inciter
les filières de passeurs à eux doubler
d'ardeur pour faire venir encore plus il
ya des femmes et des enfants la rue que
fait-on concrètement
mais concrètement et bien on l'est
évidemment s'il ya des besoins de
médecine d'urgence et c'était à eux mis
en oeuvre mais ensuite on expulse on
explique c'est la seule manière d'en
sortir
sinon et bien c'est au lieu de tarir le
flux est bien et on va l'amplifier
et c'est ce qui se passe depuis
maintenant des années et quand les
personnes qui se promènent avec la
la charité en bandoulière en histoire
faut les accueillir c'est ceux qui sont
responsables des dragons méditerranée
c'est parce qu on les incite à venir
qu'on leur dit vous serez accueillis
vous ne serez pas expulser même si vous
entré illégalement qu'ils prennent des
risques inconsidérés
qu'ils viennent et qu'ils sont entre les
mains de filières criminelles
ils sont entre les mains de filières
criminelles qui gagnent de l'argent qui
les traitent pire que des animaux et qui
est qui et qui se moquent éperdument
cannes un certain qu'il qui meurent lors
de la traversée
donc est ce qu'on continue avec ce
modèle là où est-ce qu'on au contraire
ont fait preuve de fermeté parce que la
fermeté c'est l'humanité si on veut
justement les protéger et éviter des
drames
eh bien il faut faire en sorte qu'ils ne
puissent pas venir il faut d'ailleurs
empêché les flux de dès le départ des
côtes de l'afrique du nord ou de libye
parce qu'aujourd'hui
en réalité on traite le problème très
tardivement lorsqu'ils arrivent sur les
côtes ac voilà c'est pas une attitude
responsable et la commission européenne
qui doit proposer un d'ici fin septembre
je crois des règles justement pour une
gestion équilibrée entre les différents
pays de ces migrants équilibré entre
responsabilité solidarité pour vous ça
doit être quoi ces règles pour vous
c'est on accueille plus personne mais
l'union européenne ne sort pas de son
logiciel de son schéma qui consiste à
dire on va faire venir cette immigration
il assume beaucoup y compris des
commissaires européens ont dit qu'on
avait besoin de cette immigration pour
équilibrer par exemple le système des
retraites
évidemment complètement faux on a un
chômage de masse qui fait que cette
immigration ajoute 2 voilà de deux la
précarité sociale et des drames à une
situation déjà difficile dans beaucoup
de nos pays donc l'une je crois qu'il
faut rien attendre de l'union européenne
en revanche il doit y avoir une vraie
coopération entre les nations pour
protéger les frontières et en
particulier les frontières sud puisqu'il
ya quatre ou cinq pays aurait été qu'ils
sont concernés ya la grèce et la
bulgarie
il ya l'italie la france et l'espagne
qui sont les pays en première ligne de
cette immigration clandestine mais il
faut que moi c'est à dire les choses on
les présente comme des réfugiés
ce ne sont pas des réfugiés on le
présente comme des comme des gens qui
aurait une légitimité à venir dans le
pays ce n'est pas le cas ils ont pas ils
viennent ils n'ont pas vocation à rester
et c'est ce discours de fermeté qui
évitera les dames et évidemment il faut
aussi être capable de vendre et
politique
dans les pays d'émigration il faut
stabiliser la situation en libye il faut
mettre en place des hotspots pour que
ceux qui voudraient faire une demande
d'asile puisse la faire dans les dans
les pays africains et ne pas les faire
en arrivant sur le continent européen
je crois que l'union européenne
n'apporterait aucune vraie solution eelv
équipe avait pas un pacte sur
l'immigration dans tout le monde voit
bien qui va ajouter du laxisme au
laxisme et donc en ajoutant du laxisme
au laxisme
on ajoutera des drames au g un mot sur
ces tensions qui montent en méditerranée
orientale entre la turquie et la grèce
et erdogan qui avertit désormais
emmanuel macron de ne pas chercher
querelle à la turquie et qui le menacent
même monsieur macron vous n'avez pas
fini d'avoir des ennuis avec moi dit il
est ce que vous soutenez emmanuel macron
sur ce sujet oui je le soutiens dans ce
qu'il a pu dire sur la turquie qui est
une analyse juste et mais maintenant il
faut que ça se traduise en actes la
turquie se comporte de manière
belliqueuse à l'égard des nations
européennes de la france notamment pas
seulement d'ailleurs c'est à dire les
actions militaires qu'il mène en libye
les actions minutes les militaires qu'il
mène au kurdistan les le la pression
migratoire qui l'exercent délibérément à
l'égard de l'europe les insultes qu'il
profère la transformation de la basique
c'est plus symbolique mais c'est pas
moins important de la basilique
sainte-sophie en mosquée voilà tout ça
ce sont des actes d'hostilité affiché à
l'égard de l'europe
quelle est la réponse des nations
européennes jusqu'à maintenant
absolument rien voilà erdogan se place
dans une logique de bras de fer il faut
faire le pas de faire
or on dispose d'atouts considérables la
turquie je le rappelle en 20 ans et de
l'otan il ya évidemment un sujet ya un
soutien il ya deux sujets il y avait la
question de la légitimité de l'otan sous
sa forme actuelle
on se souvient que ça a été construit
dans la dans le cas de la menace
soviétique n'existe plus et évidemment
et à deuxième question c'est de savoir
si la turquie doit faire partie d'une
alliance militaire avec nous alors que
de manière évidente elle défend les
intérêts qui en tous points ne sont pas
les nôtres
bon mais faisons bras de fer l'union
européenne a versé 50 milliards d'euros
à la turquie depuis 20 ans au titre de
la banque européenne d'investissement au
titre des fonds de préadhésion au titre
des fonds versés pour maîtriser les flux
migratoires
quel est quelle est la réponse de la
turquie la turquie nous insultent nous
menacer de submerge bon donc on peut
évidemment arrêter ces subventions
européennes ça c'est la première étape
et on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
la turquie est en union douanière
absence de droits de douane avec l'union
européenne depuis 1995
voilà elle fait l'essentiel de son
commerce extérieur sur le marché
européen vert par ses exportations vers
le marché européen
il suffit de remettre en cause cette
union douanière on peut parfaitement le
faire pour qu évidemment il ne vient les
mandrins cessonnais torsion économique
dure pour la turquie
voilà or donc non seulement le fait pas
mais aucune de ces menaces ne brandit
alors même qu'à dogan multiplie les
provocations
donc ça pose toujours le même problème
c'est une espèce c'est une union
européenne qui loin de nous donner une
force collective nous donne une suite
d'impuissance collective
allez on va passer à l'actualité de
votre parti le rassemblement national et
c'est d'abord marion maréchal qui a
fustigé les républicains dans une
interview ce week-end au journal le
figaro
nous allons assister à la mort des
républicains dit l écouter ce que lui a
répondu l'un des membres du parti c'est
renaud muselier le président de la
région sud il était hier l'invité du
grand jury rtl lci le figaro qui se
trompent
elles vont la tuer c'est à dire d'un à
gagner aux régionales contre elle avec
le soutien des forces qui voulait pas du
front national et quand on regarde
aujourd'hui la façon dont on gère la
région donc elle est partie de la région
dès son groupe qui était de 42 n'est
plus qu'à 31
c'est donc elle sait à la disparue
localement et son groupe a explosé
localement et à l'intérieur de sa
famille duras nationale j'ai pas
vraiment l'impression qu'elle se
renforce pour pour donner des leçons à
quiconque
donc c'est plutôt elle qui est morte aux
régionales a gagné plus tôt les
municipales à l'exception de marseille
ou dans l'ensemble de la région où il
était soit disant si fort on leur a pris
une ville
et donc on avance en ce sens voilà c'est
plutôt elle qui est mort très pour
renaud muselier qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez vous c'est de la polémique un
peu dérisoire marion maréchal a fait le
choix de quitter la vie politique
partisane électorale donc c'est un choix
qu'elle a fait et donc elle l a été
honnête avec les électeurs en quittant
aussi sont ses mandats de député et de
conseiller régional
mais renaud muselier sa tête de liste de
l'époque était christian estrosi ce
n'est pas un hommage à lier le candidat
a donné la feuille de route des
républicains pour les prochaines années
c'est de se rallier immédiatement et
sans condition à emmanuel macron est
d'ailleurs un homme et geôliers lui même
a multiplié les gages ou les
déclarations finalement de compatibilité
en quelque sorte avec emmanuel macron on
voit bien que les républicains
aujourd'hui sans une situation où il se
positionne de plus en plus en supplétifs
du gouvernement actuel en supplétifs des
manuels macro et c'est sans doute pas du
tout ce que les électeurs des
républicains attendent moi je suis pas
en train de me délecter des républicains
qui sont effondrées tout m'adresser
tendre la main à ses très nombreux
électeurs qui partagent nos constats sur
la question des migrations il faut de la
fermeté sur l'insécurité qui est un des
grands angles morts des grandes
faiblesses de ce gouvernement qui
veulent des protections connu mais qui
veulent de la liberté d'entreprendre en
france qui veulent baisser la fiscalité
enfin sur tous ces sujets là je pense
que beaucoup d'électeurs des
républicains qui sont d'accord avec ce
que dit la rassemblement national nous
ne nous l'attendons la main parce que
cela permet de dire qu'on va assister à
la mort des républicains quand on va par
exemple le résultat des dernières
municipales où ils ont remporté plus de
la mauvaise que celle de plus de 9000 à
est ce que c'est la victoire et sa
marque ainsi mal en point que les
élections municipales ce sont les maires
qui se présente sans étiquette c'est le
jeu des municipales d'ailleurs c'est pas
quand je dis ça c'est pas nous c'est pas
face aux critiques méritées les
républicains en temps aux parties une
profite ne profite pas de ceux de ses
victoires municipale parce que
finalement ce sont pas des maires qui
ont mis en avant le hajj est politique
le dernier score en date des
républicains derniers résultats à
l'étoile en date à une élection
nationale c'était européenne
il ya un peu plus d'un an la public en
fait 8 % des voix donc je pense que
c'est un parti qui est très mal en point
mais il était mal en point pour une
raison très simple c'est la ligne
politique de christian jacob de françois
baroin ou de valérie pécresse c'est la
ligne politique du magnat crown est ce
que sur un seul sujet sur un seul grand
sujet
on peut voir une différence
significative entre les responsables des
républicains que je viens de citer par
exemple qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
les codecs de l'état voilà qu'il nous
dise en quoi parce que finalement ce
qu'il a fait notamment la de la
transformation
oui il n'empêche marion maréchal redit
ce que robert ménard le maire de béziers
avait dit c'est à dire avec marine le
pen on ne peut pas dépasser leur
assemblée nationale
comment faire l'union des droites et est
ce possible avec marine le pen et
quoique c'est même pas la question de
l'union et droite évidemment qu'il faut
s'adresser à ses nombreux électeurs de
droite qui sont déboussolés qui voit que
les républicains défendent plus mais
au-delà de ça faut rassembler les
français c'est ce que fait aujourd'hui
le rassemblement national toutes les
critiques sont légitimes et évidemment
ce qui s'est possiblement ceux qui sont
à l'extérieur du mouvement ou qui ont
quitté la politique partisane on peut
être plus de liberté de ton et et on
peut l'accepter mais mais la critique
elle doit aussi être constructive et
c'est ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
y compris à titre personnel à robert
ménard c'est que il peut pas il peut
très bien voir que nous n'avons pas
encore gagné ça c'est un constat
mais en même temps essayer de participer
le plus utilement possible à nos
victoires futures et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui car trop de choses par
marine le pen c'est encore elle la
maille candidats connus il ya un constat
simple
quelle est la force d'opposition
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui et j ai même
qu'elle est la seule vraie force
politique d'opposition parler de leur
parti elle ne répondait pas sur marine
le pen nicolas mais c'est le
rassemblement national et de marine le
pen étant la président de la dirigeante
du rassemblement national bas c'est elle
qui naturellement la légitimité pour
concourir pour mener cette bataille
présidentielle c'est plus un choix de
raison qu'un choix de coeur j'aime bien
ça je dis simplement qu'elle est en
situation vous savez la politique est
faite de situation voilà nous défendons
des idées nous sommes une force
politique incontournable marine le pen
et des la dirigeante de notre mouvement
elle a une légitimité assez naturel être
candidate alors il on peut toujours les
uns et les autres peuvent avoir leurs
commentaires sur la situation
mais aujourd'hui je
je note que d'ailleurs ces critiques il
n'y a pas de proposition concrète
voilà donc marine le pen se prépare à
l'élection présidentielle l'a dit
d'ailleurs avec avec beaucoup de
franchise en français tôt à l'avant s'il
ya beaucoup de candidats dans
différentes alliés politiques qui font
qu'ils font mine de ne pas se préparer à
la présidentielle alors qu'en fait ils
pensent qu'à ça je pense qu'à la
franchise l'honnêteté de le dire nous
nous y préparons mais nous nous y
préparons dans une démarche de
rassemblement alors ils sont tous les
français qui viennent d'horizons parfois
très différents et qui peuvent se
rassembler sur notre projet de
redressement national
face à un emmanuel macron dont on voit
bien qu'il a qu'il n'a cessé de
fragiliser la france sur la scène
internationale et peut-être plus encore
à l'intérieur depuis trois ans et demi
justement vous parlez de rassemblement
marion maréchal dans cette même
interview au figaro dit quiconque
regarde le fonctionnement du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui voit
bien que ce n'est pas le rassemblement
qui est à l'oeuvre
vous même vous avez été écarté un choix
de la commission d'investiture du
rassemblement national
est-ce qu'à la raison est ce qu'il n'ya
pas de rassemblement est ce que vous
avez compris cette décision est ce que
aujourd'hui vous vous sentez à l'écart à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale et
j'ai un certain nombre de
responsabilités dans le mouvement je
demande du bureau exécutif dans notre
groupe parlementaire au parlement
européen qui fait que j'ai pas j'ai pas
besoin d'être membre de toutes les
réunions de travail du présent à toutes
les commissions vous est expliqué ce
choix pourquoi vous avez été carté
league mais encore une fois ceux qui
sont d'organisation interne qui relève
de la responsabilité de marie le pen
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler avec elle
mais je vais pas vous savez on peut
avait cyniquement l'organisation c'est
votre proximité avec marion maréchal
mais il sait pas une question de
proximité personnelles ou politiques
moi je suis un des dirigeants du
rassemblement national
et ça ça n'a pas changé du tout et pour
le reste on peut avoir des partis
politiques parfois des discussions
parfois même des différences et
d'ailleurs c'est autant que possible
c'est bien qu'elle s'exprime à
l'intérieur du mouvement et pas
forcément ça les plateaux de télévision
mais honnêtement est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que ces questions
d'organisation somme toute assez
mineures c'est ce qui intéresse les
français aujourd'hui non non mais ça
arrive elle peut-être le rassemblement
l'organisation tout cas il le
fonctionnement de votre parti moi ce que
je souhaite en tout cas c est ce que
marine le pen et cartes clairement les
proches de marion maréchal de
l'organisation l'une venait chacun peut
avoir son opinion sur le sujet ait
trouvé qu'un tel serait plus légitime à
tel poste ou moins légitimes et c'est
honnêtement je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
rassemblement national se met en ordre
de marche à la fois pour les régionales
et départementales dans quelques mois
avec peut-être des histoires en
perspective se met en ordre de marche
pour la présidentielle
les initiatives c'est à dire les grandes
échéances nationales pour lesquelles les
français nous attendent et moi je
souhaite et je pense que c'est le cas et
que le rassemblement national soit un
vrai rassemblement c'est-à-dire qu'il
est cette capacité à voir évidemment des
sensibilités qui s'expriment de
personnalités s des parcours différents
où on l'a vu aux élections européennes
quand vous avez thierry mariani qu'est
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy qui
nous rejoint et qui aujourd'hui est à
nos côtés
il sera impliqué dans les batailles
futures et bien on voit bien qu'on a une
capacité pas casser sa community manager
des passages d'une manière générale d'
exception près celle ci les sénateurs
dans quinze jours si vous ne gagnez
aucune région vous à la créditer cette
idée de défaite quasi systématique et
pourquoi d'ailleurs on perdra le siège
au sénat ou pourquoi pas des régionales
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de les
garder de gagner les régions c'était
l'heure au sénat on sait très bien que
c'est lié au nombre de grands électeurs
il ya peut-être des départements où la
situation est un peu moins favorable
qu'en 2014 mais aussi département où
elle est un peu d'avoir un peu plus haut
les régionales et départementales moi je
pense que beaucoup de français qui
voudront pas ni donner de la clé des
régions à au soutien des manuels macron
ni à des présidents les républicains qui
se comportent même comme des soutiens
des manuels macro donc je pense qu'on a
la possibilité peut-être oui en effet de
conquérir des légendes et des
partenaires justement rapidement nous
respectons nicolas vous serez candidat
aux régionales en normandie
écoutez j'ai fait acte de candidature
auprès de nos instances et la décision
sera prise dans quelques ça veut dire
qu'elle ne va pas de soi vous êtes
conseiller régional ans déjà
oui je suis la région normande coûté aux
mots je considère qu'il ya un
fonctionnement interne et que tout le
monde se doit s'appliquer à tout le
monde y compris aux dirigeants du
mouvement
vous le savez qu'en europe la décision
on prendra la décision dans le cadre de
notre bureau exécutif pour l'ensemble
des régions dans les semaines qui
viennent
et merci beaucoup merci nicolas v
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
pascal seulement votre place nicolas bay
ce sera olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti social
listons pas tout de suite au club des
territoires